concerne la conception de cet ep il faut
savoir qu'en 2019 j'avais décidé
d'arrêter catégoriquement la musique et
tout ce qui avait un lien justement avec
la musique
et puis finalement la passion était plus
forte et donc j'ai pris la décision de
tout produit en moi même voilà et je me
suis donné à deadline de décembre 2020
pour pouvoir voilà sortir un projet
solide donc est d'abord sortie des
titres de manière aléatoire on puisse
découvrir mon univers dans sa globalité
et pendant le confinement je me suis dit
allez les singles la fin les titres
comme ça ne suffisent pas il faut il te
faut un projet plus solide et c'est donc
pendant le compliment que j'ai eu l'idée
de produire cet ep de 5 titres donc
j'écris j'écris trois nouveaux titres et
j'ai ajouté deux titres que j'avais déjà
écrit en 2017
voilà donc c'est un flic 7 pb pour
qualifier mon style musical
je ne pourrai malheureusement pas
utilisé un seul mot puisque c'est vrai
que c'est un mélange de plusieurs styles
musicaux
je dirais que qu'il se situe au
carrefour de tout ce qui est un peu
jazzy soul blues groove trappe reggae
tradition enfin voila c'est un doux
mélange de tout ça et voilà je pense que
c'est le reflet de mes influences
musicales de mon parcours et dans mes
origines